you know normally I don't make videos
like this right because I don't really
like being a negative Nancy you know for
the most part when it comes to when it
comes to talking about things like I
don't like to be a down I like to keep
the channel positive but here's the
thing man like people have been asking
me non-stop to make a video about my
thoughts on x-men Dark Phoenix and if
I'm gonna go see x-men Dark Phoenix and
and someone let me tell you something
I'm not gonna go see that movie and I
never was like I watched that in okay
here's the thing I had it on good
authority that movie was gonna be
garbage and the reason why was because
everybody phoned it in and I was like
there's there's no way that I'm gonna go
see that like like not a chance and
here's the reason why right like the
when it comes to the x-men when it comes
to the x-men movies from Fox there had
been like three redeeming qualities in
that movie first was was well I guess
maybe for the first was like Ian
McKellen Ian McKellen ah the name of
whoever was yeah Ian McKellen I think it
was who played um who played like
Magneto
like the old version of magneto Michael
Fassbender who played the younger
version James McAvoy as young Xavier and
then like Patrick Stewart as the older
Xavier and then like Wolverine and for
the most part like those were the only
redeeming factors of those movies like
you go into something like Days of
Future past sure that movie was great
that's because it's based on an amazing
story people give that movie way too
much credit they're just kind of like
man Foxx did a fantastic job with this
movie no they made a movie almost
shot-for-shot with the exception of a
couple changes based on one of the most
like celebrated x-men stories of all
time right it'd be like it'd be like if
some random studio came out I made a
movie about triumphant women right we're
like Doctor Strange and Doctor Doom team
up and go to hell to free as mom's soul
like that story was amazing and anybody
who makes it they'd have to
intentionally go out of their way to
screw it up
so so I mean but but like by and large
you you can't look at like the x-men as
a whole in the Fox universe and say like
well I mean you know it's great they
just kind of missed it a couple times no
it's bad they just got it right a couple
times like that's that's all that is and
that's all it ever was and so when I
look at something like Dark Phoenix but
as soon as that movie was announced I
was like that movie's gonna be terrible
and the reason why is because the Dark
Phoenix is not a story that you do like
that you can't just throw the Dark
Phoenix out like you have to build up to
it right
it would be like if they brought in a
nose as the main villain for Avengers 1
and then killed him off how
anticlimactic would that be how dumb
would that be a villain like that a
character like that needs time to grow
and to kind of become this worth
background menacing concept that's
looming out there in the distance and
you know it's only a matter of time
before they show up and when they do all
hell's gonna break loose like that's the
feeling you need to have when you look
at something like the Dark Phoenix okay
well here's a here's a good example look
at the Marvel Cinematic Universe right
like I'm the whole basis behind trends
right as it said somebody somewhere
comes along and does something and then
like everybody in the world copies it
right like it's the nature of setting
trends like like look at the Marvel
Cinematic Universe kneel like you had
Marvel who is on the verge of bankruptcy
they went to Merrill Lynch took out a
loan for five hundred million dollars
and said let's make Iron Man and so they
so then they hire a Robert Downey jr.
they bring him and nobody thought he was
gonna succeed Marvel had to go on a
campaign and convince the world he
wasn't a robot and then they released
the movie and to the surprise of pretty
much every single person in the
movie-going audience the film was
fantastic but what if they had killed
Iron Man at the end of the first movie
you wouldn't have cared you would have
cared that Tony Stark died you would
have just been like well Dan that's
crazy and they're like on to the next
one that's it but he died at the end of
Avengers in game why because he had ten
years because I don't care what anybody
ever tells me the first ten years of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe was the rise
and fall of Tony Stark that's all it was
it was the story of Tony Stark everybody
else was a supporting character and that
doesn't mean it and I'm not trying to
tear down like Tom Holland or or Chris
Evans or anybody they all did fantastic
and their roles were amazing and I'll
talk about them here in a second but the
overarching theme was Tony Stark and
Iron Man one went from this weapons
manufacturer who was a playboy pissing
his money away not caring anything about
anybody but himself to a guy who
realized hey there's consequences for
the weapons I make donned this makeshift
Iron Man suit in the middle of the
freaking desert and then turn around and
dawn like all these other Iron Man suit
and become became a super hero and then
he formed the Avengers because Nick Fury
wants him to and then he starts
recruiting all these people and you see
him you see the character of Tony Stark
to the point where like heat of vols and
he grows and then he gets to the point
where at Avengers in game like we felt
for him because it was like okay they're
in a new timeline now
he's got a daughter like sure things
suck for everybody else but for the most
part toy Sarkis found peace and
happiness and like we know that if they
go back in time and he goes like if he
gives them the tools they need to go
back in time and to take the Infinity
stones bring him to the present day and
stop the snap that under I guess undo
everything he's gonna lose his child
because that timelines not contagious
anymore but he's gonna lose everything
he loves now of course things kind of
got you know caught up in the market and
everything sort of changed up anyway and
his daughter still there but the overall
gist of all this is that in that moment
at that time we were afraid he was gonna
lose his happiness like he was gonna
lose his child the one thing that he
always wanted like we thought he was
gonna lose it and like we felt for that
at the end of the movie when Ironman
dies people were crying in the theater
like I was I was sitting down there I
was sitting down there in the front row
but you've got you've got Caitlyn from
that sea monster you've got her fiance
duck
you got myself I'm sorry you got uh you
got Mariah you got myself you have like
Danny got Houston you got a handful of
others you've got like DJ like comics
torian's personal trainer you got comic
store and you got his brother Andy you
got his his wife Edith you've got
Vinny's Vinnie's wife Natalie we've got
like the whole crew right like like we
rolled into that [ __ ] like v team's
strong but it's like we go in there
we're watching this movie Iron Man dies
at the end and it's nothing but tears
it's like when Mufasa died in the Lion
King it was like the saddest thing ever
that wasn't a dry eye in the house I
even teared up a little bit you know me
was the Oh golly gee a single tear rolls
down my cheek but it was like even I
teared up a little bit because you felt
for his character because you looked at
that he was like oh my god III it makes
sense that they would but I didn't think
they actually could like like you you
you you you you you live in that moment
and you say damn
Iron Man died now you extrapolate that
out to the other characters right like
Tom Holland is spider-man
it looks like the most fun ever like Tom
Holland is spider-man and I don't care
what anybody tells me he's hiding powers
like like he's like the perfect person
to play spider-man because he's young
he's vibrant and he obviously enjoys the
hell out of what he does he surprises
fans on a whim I mean things like that
like like like seems someone who kind of
brings a character to life in a way
to wear it almost like transcends the
silver screen and steps into the real
life that's a hard thing to find you
look at the character of Chris Evans
right like Captain America the the like
fighting freedom is is what this guy
basically was he knew where his life was
going he understood how things were
transpiring and he was gonna settle down
and have a life with Peggy Carter and
then what happens like the Red Skull
gets teleported away because he tries to
mess with the Cosmic Cube Captain
America has to fly this thing down into
like this this thing's crashing into the
Arctic he ends up crashing along with it
and he's frozen in ice for 70 years like
that everything he knew and loved was
gone
in the blink of an eye his future with
Peggy Carter gone his future with all of
his friends and family gone his future
with Bucky Barnes gone Oh every single
thing he knew and loved gone like it was
it was out just like that and he had no
idea he was just frozen in ice the guy
gets thawed out into a world he doesn't
know and then somehow like having to
come to grips with all that all the
while knowing that life he knew is
totally gone he's trying to eat Captain
America is a man out of time trying to
make his way in the world and which one
of us have never been in that situation
right like anybody who's moved to a new
school and felt out of place
anybody who moved to a whole new town
and felt out of place anybody who
started a new job and felt how to place
feeling out of place and the fear of
failure are the things that govern the
life of Captain America and every single
one of us have felt that way so every
single person that looked at Captain
America understood that the character
for a Thor Thor was a guy who was
selfish and who was who who didn't care
about anybody but himself a lot like
Iron Man a spoiled little brat was cast
down and forced to live on earth with
human beings the most basic human like
the most basic things in the entirety of
the universe you have like these
characters like a Kree could show up on
earth and punch a hole to the chest of a
human like humans are that weak in the
Marvel Universe Thor is forced to live
among them he learns humility begins to
realize hey maybe the universal that
really revolve around me and goes on to
become a superhero and then you get into
infinity war and then you get into
endgame and the entire arc of Thor in
those two movies is he has his chance to
save everyone and then he fails and so
the entirety of Avengers endgame is Thor
operates under the belief that half the
life his universes half life the
universe is dead because he screwed up
because he missed his one shot like
that's a huge amount of weight in a huge
amount
to carry and you see it on it you see it
in his character you see it in the
character as he goes through the movie
he got all fat he's the Big Lebowski
like mother when the movie first starts
talking a new master 69 like he's gonna
be able to find me like like all these
things are are going on live with all
these different characters Ronin the guy
loses his entire family like Hawkeye he
was a character that nobody liked I
didn't care about Hawkeye Hawkeye and
black widow people who could shoot
accurate rahu like there's a world full
of assassins with with people like that
the hand could take those guys out they
don't matter and then like Hawkeye loses
his entire family just they get dusted
and then he and then like he goes on a
warpath
right like goes on a warpath and it was
amazing Scott Lane the guy that nobody
took seriously is a guy who comes up
with the only possibility they have just
save the universe all these characters
have all these amazing arcs and they
they move in a forward direction and the
characters evolve and the characters
grow and then you have x-men Dark
Phoenix somewhere along the line and
Jean Grey has powers and then she's kind
of emo now she's every fifteen-year-old
girl ever and then like she does
whatever is it she does and then he goes
on war that it's like okay who cares
though because like she's not relatable
none of the characters in that movie
outside of like Michael Fassbender and
James McAvoy and maybe one or two other
people are interesting or relatable or
resonate me would resonate with me on
any level I can almost guarantee you
most people who went into that theater
and I guarantee somebody probably died
in that movie most people who went into
that theater like they they went in
there they watched that film somebody
probably died and you wouldn't see any
of the reactions that you saw from x-men
from I'm sorry from from Avengers in
game because there's no character
building there the problem with the Fox
x-men movies is there a series of
successive films and neither what none
of them have really seem to have
anything to do with each other not
emotionally in terms of them definitely
not in terms of how like the characters
grow and the characters evolved it's
just a series of successive stories and
and it doesn't do anything for anyone
you don't grow attached to those
characters I mean I love Michael
Fassbender's magneto when he was an
x-men date or the x-men first class
because the guy's entire life was just
like a struggle he'd know nothing but
like loss and sacrifice so that was
interesting because on a personal level
that resonated with me but like James
McAvoy is is as Xavier to me that was
interesting because he was a guy trying
to make his way
aside from a couple of different
characters I didn't care and I still
don't and that's the crappy theme
because I've ever read in the x-men
comics for 25 years
not even to sound arrogant I'm probably
in the top 1% if not the 1% of the 1%
most knowledgeable x-men people out
there on the face of the world and
that's not to be arrogant it's because
it's probably true I mean I guess you
get to sit me alongside all these people
started asking questions don't like that
but I've been reading it's been that
long there's that much a part of my life
and I'm that attached to the comics and
so to see them kind of portrayed in the
Fox x-men universe we're like Hugh
Jackman is the only character that
anybody ever really seems to talk about
her care about it's kind of a travesty
because at the end of the day in the
comics and it like Wolverine hasn't been
that interesting since the mid 1980s
like Wolverine has been just kind of a
character who was there and attacks
people and dies and comes back multiple
times since like 1987 so so like I mean
it's it's it kind of sucks like I look
at that movie and I look at the actor I
looked at the trailer and I can tell
just by the trailer nobody seems to care
and I can tell just by the trailer that
the movie was thrown together by by a
handful of suits sitting in a room
somewhere
like how much money can we make if we
make a movie called Dark Phoenix because
it kind of worked for x-men last and
even though that movie was garbage let's
just repeat that film change it up a
little bit throw it out there and then
call it something new and that's the
worst thing because there have been some
good x-men films like Logan but like
Logan was a great film it was a
deconstruction of Wolverine what do we
get if we get a version of what we love
Wolverine who doesn't really pop his
claws who doesn't really like to hear
things up and said he's a guy who's just
like trying to make his way and wants to
be left the hell alone
like what what kind of movie would that
look like it's awesome it's basically
Wolverine Meets Unforgiven right it was
it was a great film and I loved it like
there's a couple here and there like
x-men Days of Future past is another one
that's when apocalypse is terrible
that's been one two and three we're all
bad like like I looked at those films
and it's just like there's more misses
than hits because they're not being made
by people who were fan of superheroes
they're made by people who are trying to
make money off of superheroes and
failing disastrously because the movies
are making our garbage and this is the
last film that was supposed to be done
for the x-men if ever there were going
to be a great movie that should have set
the x-men off on their on the right
unlike the right path I said okay like
you guys have done an awesome job we're
setting you off you guys are gonna ride
off into the Sun
set and is happily ever after roll
credits roll a theme from Magnificent
Seven like if that's if that's what we
were gonna get then like it shouldn't
have been dark Phoenix that's a movie
you build up to over the course of ten
years dark phoenix is like the
equivalent of a vendor's in game it
takes time to get to that point it takes
time to build that up because you have
to feel for the characters you have to
understand the struggle you have to
understand how hard it is for a
Wolverine don't like have to face the
fact it has to kill Jean bright that's a
big thing you got cut from the whole
movie because of age differences I guess
but like button you know the character
of Cyclops like like losing his wife
like Cyclops quits the Yeti in the
comics
Cyclops quits the x-men after Jean Grey
dies to the end of Dark Phoenix and it's
just like the saddest thing ever because
the guy's whole life has been thrown
disarray the only thing he knew and
loved is gone
so he's like I can't do this anymore the
guy takes off to Anchorage Alaska ends
up like ends up vana Jean Grey's clone
and they pop out a kid 1980s comics
don't ask why though the whole point
behind this is that when it comes to
movies when it comes to the film Dark
Phoenix I'm not gonna see it because I
know what it is I can I can watch it go
watch Elmo I can I knew exactly what I
know exactly what it is it's a cookie
cutter x-men movie just like so many
other had them before that just takes
the name of a really popular story slaps
it on to some actors you don't really
seem to care about the weather what
happens with the film and then they call
it a day right the best and that's kind
of a travesty because sophie Turner is
an amazing actress like in Game of
Thrones she's fantastic
she's an amazing actress James McAvoy
he's a fantastic actor Michael
Fassbender a fantastic actor the people
in the film are fantastic actors the
problem is the film itself is ass
because it was written to be that way
because there was no real thought given
to how does this translate a story into
her into a great film the question was
like how much cash can we make off this
and how fast can we make it that's the
problem and that's that's why I'm not
going to see the movie because the
movies asked I knew it was asked before
it came out and I know it's still gonna
be asked so I'm not going to see that
thing well that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys are the sub button if you
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
please
[Music]